all right this is a pepper panic saga
level 2 23
walkthrough tutorial video
i'm going to play through the level and
try to complete it and i'm going to
explain the decisions i make as i go
if you played this one already you know
it's tough and the hardest part is
getting the purple explosions
the purple peppers don't fall onto the
board as often as the green and the blue
which makes it
very difficult with the small spaces to
get those to explode
there's going to be some timers there's
a fixed number of timers on this board
so there's
i guess always 10 of them at one time
that includes the petrified one
so
we got six here and so four more are
going to drop
i look around to see what the worst area
is and this one i guess is the worst
because there's no purple peppers at all
in it
and i'm going to get the timers to fall
we just hope that they won't be purple
one of them was so you see that like two
of them fell in
now two more following so now we can
just
now there's no more that are going to
fall until we remove one of them so
we'll just uh abandon that section
completely for now
so we're trying to grow the purple
as fast as we can
and
and
um
it you know it takes a little bit of
help to get that done
yeah
this is this is
really important to explode this purple
pepper if we can
all right so there goes one that that's
that's good they start out with one even
one is
fantastic so
now
they're all the purples are separated so
what we want to do is get rid of one of
these orders right away
i'm not going to make the t because it's
going to remove this and that's going to
bring another timer as you can see this
timer replaced the petrified paper that
was up there
so instead what i'm going to do is just
explode this green one
and then
start a chain reaction with the blues
you know we had to kind of waste a
couple moves there because all the big
ones were in the one section and we had
to make sure the chain reaction was
gonna start
and we got a good drop there
which is nice but these timers are gonna
block us
from getting to this pepper
but um
you know we have purples together in
other areas so hopefully we'll be able
to get them all together and we'll shoot
this one
and get it a little bit bigger
and if we can we'll shoot it again so
we'll shoot this one
again i'm not going to make the tea and
it's going to make a regular 4 pepper
match
and we should be able to finish now
so we need one more
the purple that we need is here
but we need three greens as well
we're gonna lose one of our grown green
ones but
we should be able to do it still
all right make the purple get rid of
that one
and hope it this is what we wanted was
that it would set this off
and as you see as you can see like the
it's way easier to create action with
the other color so
all right so down here we have
three plus three so this will make an
explosion and it'll be able to finish
off the green order
so
going to complete the level
you see like
how important the purple is hopefully um
because it really is easier to pick up
the other orders at the end
you also see that it's difficult to just
say hey well the way to do it is just
blow up the purple peppers because
they're just not available
that readily
so that you can you know do it every
single time
hope this helps
for you to understand how to beat the
level
and
i hope you'll uh
if you have any questions you'll leave a
comment and i'll be sure to get back to
you
like us on facebook make sure you visit
our site and
share our guides if you find them
helpful so that other people can find
them
that's all we have we'll have some more
videos soon thanks
you